SMITH AND CHARLES BARKLEY.
THIS IS ALWAYS A BIG NIGHT.
>> IT'S ALWAYS SPECIAL.
WHEN YOUR PEERS, THE FANS AND
YOUR FEARS, THAT'S AWESOME.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT TONIGHT.
>> WE ALWAYS ARE.
THE WAY ALL-STARS ARE DETERMINED
HAS NOT CHANGED.
THE FAN VOTE COUNTS 50%.
PLAYER VOTE, 25%.
A MEDIA PANEL.
25%.
WHAT IS DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS IS THAT HERE TO HELP US
REVEAL THE 22 ALL-STAR STARTERS,
WE HAVE A SPECIAL GUEST.
>> A SPECIAL GUEST.
NICOLE TALBERT.
THEY HAVE TAB TLATD VOTES ON
BEHALF OF THE NBA AND HAS BEEN
KIND ENOUGH TO HAND DELIVER THE
RESULTS IN THIS BROOF CASE TO
US.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
LIVE ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> LIVE AND DIRECT HERE ON TNT.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL.
IN YEARS PAST, WE WOULD HAVE A
LITTLE HEADS UP.
WHEN THE SHOW STARTED --
>> WE WOULD ALREADY KNOW.
>> WE KNEW.
IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW, YOU KNEW.
>> I CALLED OUT, LOVE YOU,
RAYMOND.
>> BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA JUST LIKE
YOU ALL AT HOME.
WE DO NOT KNOW.
THIS IS ENVELOPE NUMBER ONE.
>> SHOW WHO IT IS.
>> THE WESTERN CONFERENCE FRONT
COURT.
♪♪
>> YOU'RE THE FIRST TO KNOW.
>> THE CAPTAIN, THE LEADING VOTE
GETTER IN THE WEST, LeBRON
JAMES.
>> OKAY.
I THINK WE KNEW THAT.
>> 18th STRAIGHT APPEARANCE IN
2022, IN HIS 19th SEASON.
GIVING THE LAKERS 29 POINTS A
GAME, EIGHT REBOUNDS, SIX
ASSISTS, SHOOTING 62%.
THE MOST NBA GAMES THIS YEAR
WITH 22, AND HE'S GOING TO BE A
CAPTAIN AGAIN, AND SO FAR AS A
CAPTAIN, HE IS 4-0.
>> ONE OF THE GREATEST PLAYERS
WE'VE EVER SEEN.
CONGRATULATIONS TO LeBRON AND
HIS FAMILY.
JUST HAVE TO REPEAT WHAT KENNY
SAID.
WE KNEW HE WOULD MAKE IT.
>> WE TALK ABOUT GOATS, MICHAEL,
KOBE, SHAQ.
WHATEVER.
HOWEVER, HE IS THE BEST PLAYER
FOR THE LONGEST IN THE NBA.
I DON'T THINK ANY PLAYER HAS
BEEN AS GREAT AS LONG.
>> OH, MY GOD!
>> AS LONG.
18 YEARS.
>> TELL ME A PLAYER THIS OLD WHO
IS IS THIS GOOD.
>> KAREEM?
>> KAREEM WAS GOOD.
HE WAS NOT THIS GOOD THIS OLD.
>> I'LL TELL YOU THIS ABOUT
LeBRON.
IF HE DOES WIN THE SCORING
TITLE, HE WOULD BE THE OLDEST
SCORER.
>> THIS GOOD THIS OLD.
I'M TELLING YOU.
>> WE COULD DEBATE THE MERITS OF
LEBRON JAMES IF YOU LIKE BUT I
WOULD RATHER GET TO THE OTHER
TWO STARTERS IN THE WESTERN
CONFERENCE FRONT COURT.
NIKOLA JOKIC, THE REIGNING MVP.
>> THIS IS A BIG ONE.
>> AND ANDREW WIGGINS OF THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
>> CONGRATULATIONS.
>> TO JOKIC FIRST, THE FOURTH
STRAIGHT APPEARANCE, AVERAGING
26, 14 AND 8.
HE LEADS IN DOUBLE DOUBLES AND
HE LEADS THE LEAGUE IN TRIPLE
DOUBLES WITH 11.
SO NIKOLA JOKE IB JOINS LeBRON
JAMES IN THE WESTERN CONFERENCE
FRONT COURT.
AND HOW ABOUT ANDREW WIGGINS?
FIRST TIME ALL-STAR, SHOOTING A
CAREER BEST.
AVERAGING 18 POINTS, FOUR
REBOUNDS, TWO ASSISTS FOR THE
2015, ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
>> HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> CONGRATULATIONS TO ANDREW
WIGGINS.
THE FIRST TIME ALL-STAR.
>> NOT TO MENTION THE JOB ON
DEFENSE.
>> WHEN HE WAS, WHEN THEY TRADED
FOR HIM, I THINK SOME PEOPLE
LAUGHED WHEN I AM --
>> I SAID GO IN THERE.
HE COULD BE AN ALL-STAR.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T SEE
IT.
I DID ONLY BECAUSE THE ROLE
WOULD CHANGE AS THE PRIMARY
SCORER.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE GREAT AND
AN ALL STAR IN THE SECONDARY
ROLE.
NOW BEING IN THE SECONDARY ROLE,
HIS 18 OF 20 POINTS BECOME MUCH
MORE MEANINGFUL.
IF YOU'RE COUNTING ON A GUY TO
GET 25 AND HE GETS 20, OH!
IF YOU'RE COUNTING ON 14 AND HE
GETS 20, THEN HE'S AN ALL-STAR.
>> WHEN YOU'RE SUCH A YOUNG
TALENT, THEY EXPECT YOU TO KNOW
HOW TO WIN.
HE DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO WIN.
WHEN HE WENT TO GOLDEN STATE,
SIMILAR TO WHAT JAFELL MAGEE
DID.
DID HE THAT AND I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE HIM AND HIS FAMILY.
>> WHAT THEY REALLY DID WAS PUT
HIM IN HIS RIGHT SPOT.
HE CAN'T BE YOUR BEST PLAYER.
WHEN HE WAS IN MINNESOTA, PEOPLE
THINK WHEN YOU GET MAX MONEY,
LIKE HE HAS TO BE THE THIRD OR
FOURTH BEST PLAYER.
PEOPLE ASSUME WHEN YOU GET
MONEY, YOU'RE AUTOMATICALLY, I'M
THE MAN.
ANDREW WIGGINS IS A GOOD PLAYER.
BUT YOU NEED TO BE THE THIRD OR
FOURTH BEST AND YOU CAN BECOME
AN ALL-STAR.
IF HE'S YOUR BEST PLAYER, YOU
SAW WHAT HAPPENED.
SO HE'S IN A GREAT SITUATION.
HE CAN BE THE THIRD OR FOURTH
BEST PLAYER ON THE TEAM AND IT'S
CONGRATULATIONS.
>> NO DOUBT.
>> ALL-STAR.
>> NOW, NEXT UP, BECAUSE YOU
LIKE ME TO SHOW THIS.
>> THE WINNER IS -- LA LA LAND!
>> I CAUGHT THAT.
>> STEPHEN CURRY AND JA MORANT.
>> YEAH, YEAH.
>> WEST ALL-STARS.
FIRST TO CURRY, HIS EIGHTH
ALL-STAR GAME IN HIS 13th
SEASON.
26 POINTS A GAME, NUMBER 9.
14 30-POINT GAMES.
THE WARRIORS HAVE THE SECOND
BEST RECORD IN THE WEST.
ANOTHER FIRST TIMER AT THE
TENDER AGE OF 22.
JA MORANT.
GIVEN THE GRIZZLIES 25 POINTS A
GAME, TENTH IN THE LEAGUE, SIX
REBOUNDS, SEVEN ASSISTS, 2020
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
HE JOINS MARC GASOL AS THE ONLY
GRIZZLIES AS STARTERS IN THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
BUT HE HAS REALLY COME ON.
>> I MADE A COMMENT THE OTHER
DAY.
IT SORT OF WENT VIRAL BUT I
THINK PEOPLE MISUNDERSTOOD.
I SAID HE REMINDED ME OF KOBE.
TALK ABOUT MAMBA MENTALITY.
HIS MENTALITY AND KOBE'S
MENTALITY ARE SIMILAR.
HE KNOWS HE'S THE BEST PLAYER IN
THE LEAGUE.
THAT'S HOW HE'S SUPPOSED TO MAY.
SECOND, THIRD YEAR, DOMINATING.
A BOX OFFICE TYPE PLAYER.
PEOPLE ARE VERY HAPPY FOR HIM.
WE KNEW THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
HE DEFINITELY HAS THAT
MENTALITY.
I DON'T CARE WHO HE WILL PLAY ON
THE COURT.
THIS IS MY GAME AND I'M TAKING
OVER.
>> NUMBER ONE, CONGRATULATIONS
TO JA MORANT.
HE'S BEEN FABULOUS ALL YEAR.
HE'S HAD A COUPLE OF INJURIES.
FIRST, ONE OF THE BEST COACHING
STAFFS.
WE HAVE THIS STORY.
SO WE'RE IN THE PLAYOFFS.
HE WASN'T EVEN DRAFTED.
HE HAD JUST LEFT COLLEGE.
WE WERE ON THE SET GETTING READY
FOR THE GAME AND THIS LITTLE KID
CAME UP AND THAT, HEY, MR.
SMITH, MR. BARKLEY, I WANT TO
SAY HELLO.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
AND HE WALK AWAY.
WHO IS THAT?
I HAD NO IDEA.
WHO IS THAT LITTLE KID?
>> BECAUSE OF THE SIZE AND
STATURE.
HE PLAYS SO MUCH BIGGER.
>> HE PLAYS A LOT BIGGER.
>> WE THOUGHT HE WAS 6'4", 6'5".
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS SOMEBODY'S
KID.
>> HE WAS LIKE 110 POUNDS.
DO YOU KNOW WHO HE REMINDED ME
OF?
DAME LILLARD.
I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE BIGGER
THAN THAT.
THAT'S THE SAME THING WITH JA.
I'M HAPPY FOR HIM.
>> Mike: I WAS WATCHING THE
POSTGAME SHOW ON THE GRIZZLIES
LAST NIGHT AND HE TALKED ABOUT
HOPEFULLY GETTING THEM TO HIS
GRANDMOTHER'S TO WATCH THE SHOW
FROM THERE.
I HOPE HE WAS ABLE TO DO THAT.
AND WELCOME TO THE DARK.
THAT'S KIND OF HIS SLOGAN ABOUT
ALL THE WORK YOU DO IN THE DARK
WHEN NOBODY IS WATCHING.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE LIGHTS, IT HAS
PA